start with this
Dr
okay uh and so we're just going to move
him and you
pushing so you have to ground that and
then you have to project and you can't
if you're not grounding when you push
him you'll push you back he's got the
base he's got the in so you do have to
push him and um I would like uh Ronin
and Taylor to not take the four four and
eight you're more
here and you're going to do the same
thing so here you're as you're moving
into me I release the tension like the
bottom of the uh of the pet you see so
the sword goes up and then I release and
that's what lowers me here on the on the
ground okay it doesn't have to do with
my hand
it doesn't have to do with my hands I
just release and you'll compress into me
you see okay but my hands have been
moved and then I project that back
out we could do the 10 to two we can do
the
12 for
you're like again it it it'll do it cuz
you understand you're like really hard
there okay it's
soft see that
so when you
grab you start to push
and same no
desire same no desire
[Music]
stay
still this part does not take tension
okay for my arms
releas okay all right project but I'll
stick on the on the projection energy I
and I don't know where you're going to
get it okay so you're going to project
and then you're going to stick on the on
the other side so you're working both
your there's your Co right you're going
to co and then you're going to stick on
that side so there's going to be a lot
of young energy right as you you send
them back and that's the one you you use
to get back okay so
okay try when I when I I go you see
watch watch what Happ so in in your grip
I'm already going to start adhering so
in the
grip you projecting off and then you're
trying to catch it projecting off and
then you're trying to catch it you see
how
in the in the grip I'm already there
then I come over that's one way other
way
is but it's the same see I'm here and
I'll project but I'm already
inhering you can't
go it's not going to work you're
adhering in the grip
[Music]
on the
arm do that side
again are we going to project but I'm ad
heing you can open your grid you see I
project with the
ad I'm not going like that the ades and
then I can change the direction
it's here even though your thumbs are
closed it's in the
adhesion you
see it hearing already be with me
project that's
it okay I go so as I
go so feel the feel feel the pressure so
one yours comes
up one
increasing okay you
feel it's more friction it's not it's
not that I'm it's not that I'm pushing
down but it gets increased that would
that would be slippery you see and
you're going to get
more that okay
so PR
friction yeah yeah yes all right that's
it
right okay
okay now now we're going to move away
from the drill but everything's the same
okay so he's coming in right he's got
his young
aspect and I'm going to step to the side
and
project you're going to have to find
your ground pop on movement
[Music]
it's even if my stance is deep it's not
off my back foot it's on my back foot on
my back
foot on my
back okay I want you that clear the line
of attack get to one of the 45s and do
the pro
which we were doing already okay all
right I want you to use more young
angles so the
10 I think you can relax a little more
still a
little you still
have just
relax
relax relax
tiny
little tiny little yeah
this this part is this part
is
hard I know you can get away with
it but we hit the ground
all
right
and and
okay
here and every time you move your feet
the foot that is not moving has to find
the ground
[Music]
okay so if we if we take yesterday's
drill you
see the the EO
I IO I can do it the same exact way
everything that we just did is the same
way okay
so
when I'm here I'm not just getting out
of the
way same thing open your grip same thing
you see feel how you'll feel my skin my
skin move you see that
okay that's that's what I meant doing
inside your breath so it can move you
you see in it also brings you
in got it so I just in here and I'm
doing it
here
okay open right I have to find that I
have to find the adhesion the adhesion
is moving you see and I have to keep it
okay and I'll leave you a counter off
for now okay so I I'm in here the same
thing you see same thing coming this way
now oh
this and then I find the ground p i
aiming your Center and I find the ground
P even though I'm moving it's moving
it's not
this his body
body and let's try it